what happens when Ice Bears start losing
their ice they get stuck on land and
they get hungry when polar bears can't
find good food to eat they'll fill up on
junk food and for polar bears junk food
is human food this is a rising safety
concern for humans after working and
living off and on with polar bears for
over 12 years I know coexisting with
them can be a challenge and it will only
get more challenging as climate change
forces our species to increasingly
overlap polar bears international is
working on Innovative Technologies that
could help provide longer lead times
between when polar bears and people meet
or prevent them from mating altogether
just one example GPS tracking it can
tell us where when and why polar bears
move it's critical data the number one
most important coexistence tool we have
is our willingness to cut carbon
emissions and stop trapping so much heat
in our atmosphere the faster we switch
to clean our energies the better we can
protect future generations of polar
bears and people